this food delivery driver is furious
over the tips she got i need to speak to
you i don't think you realize where
they're coming from no no no no no no no
go home
go home no i need that thing to shut up
you chose a job where you have to it's
going to be [ __ ] up or go home they
didn't tip you go home there's nothing
you're going to do oh no they tipped her
no that's get the [ __ ] out money they
tipped her no they attempted before she
saw the tip and then she came back
all right
the driver who delivers for doordash was
captured on the homeowner's ring camera
i drove 40 minutes and it was extremely
far and i got it too early
so i don't think you realize where you
work from that's a 15 20 minute drive
it's not you need to try to drive it i
just drove it it's 40 minutes well we
decided to check for ourselves the
restaurant was in comac new york the
house was in smithtown according to
google maps that's a 5.5 mile drive and
should take only 12 minutes why did you
need to adjust your tip
to make it right so what was the tip
wow
i was waiting for that
go home go home
eight dollars eight dollars eight
dollars eight dollars that's a lot eight
dollars she was not even complaining
about
the amount of the order
she complained of how far that [ __ ] was
aida eight dollars
5.5 mile you better get the [ __ ] off my
lawn
you better get the [ __ ] off my lawn lady
go for it kick in the chest oh yeah oh
yeah drop kick hey hey
[ __ ] get the [ __ ] off my lawn the [ __ ]
is wrong with you
he said put the ass what got a pungie
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
sweet chin music get the [ __ ] off my
lawn
5.5 mile you make eight bucks
[ __ ] [ __ ] make that in an hour
or something get the [ __ ] off my lawn
and here's the thing even if you factor
in driving costs whatever car
maintenance okay eight dollar tip you
still also have the delivery of feed on
top of that which they get from each one
of them no right so
no no i'm i'm calling the whole police
you bet that at this point is
trespassing what you came back
because they gave you eight
bits be generous
be generous eight dollars and there's a
bunch of delivery drivers watching right
now who'd be like listen i'll be lucky
if i get three to four dollars
listen lady you're the reason
[ __ ] don't get tip at all okay
ungrateful [ __ ] i'm not gonna tip none
of y'all your fault it's on you
are you a
a generous tip uh tipper when it comes
to delivery to delivery yeah not
generous just normal yeah like what 10
15 10 15. okay
yeah just you know yeah i i think i feel
like with delivery is like about 15
delivery i i don't feel like i have to
yeah
if you [ __ ] if you be a [ __ ] about it
then i'll remove that [ __ ] right quick
what the hell are you looking for
i gave him an eight dollar okay
i'm gonna bring the feedback okay that's
right she took the food back
so who was in the right
[Music]
hey your credit ain't that great isn't
it i've been in that position i
understand that i might have a little
something for you the extra card you see
extra is a debit card that helps you
build your credit back up how does that
work really simple you take the extra
and your subscription you link it to
your bank account
and then extras gonna spot all the
purchases the daily purchases that you
do on that account you automatically pay
the next day and at the end of the month
italians up all the
purchases that you did it sends it to
your credit bureau voila no credit check
no fee and on top of that you can get
redeemable points and rewards that you
can use later ain't that great all that
with the extra card listen go in the
link below and you can help build your
credit back up today he might put the
link here
or maybe there just on the side whatever
go check out the link get your extra
card today
she took the food back
she's definitely fired oh yeah she's
fired she's she's she's once it's on
camera she's fired she's she really said
i'm bringing the food back
that's that's one question who raised
you welcome to another episode of karen
today karen does the list
that's what it is
that that that is what it is
bruh some people are just entitled
breath
some people are entitled as hell no i
didn't no i didn't want to i didn't want
to get out of my house to tip you or
open the door
for the ass [ __ ] you better give me my
goddamn food i ordered yeah you should
have got out and definitely yeah i would
have proved to that we went to etiquette
expert thomas farley a.k.a mr manners
even if you are unhappy with a tip you
do not ever penalize the customer by
removing the service it would be the
equivalent of a taxi driver not being
happy with your tip and saying well i
don't like that tip i'm taking you back
to where we started and dropping you off
there that would not happen doordash
told inside edition the actions of the
delivery woman were inappropriate and
grounds for deactivation i need to speak
here i need to speak to your manager
i need to speak to your manager listen i
need to speak to your manager i don't
know who you are
but that's the reason you ain't got no
friends nobody likes you [ __ ] you know
nobody likes you
you detestable people
nobody likes you that's why you have no
friends i wanna shut the [ __ ] up get off
my lawn
now you ain't got no job you dum-dum
where was that new york i wish it was in
brooklyn because there's nothing much
ain't nothing
that hurts more than a brooklyn or a
queen's stupid get my food stupid that's
stupid here differently if it's from
queens or or bro stupid that [ __ ] from
the they say
you know the rest the rest of the rest
of the state are you stupid brooklyn and
queens stupid it comes from the state
stupid sometimes i just watch them and i
don't really have words
so i'm gonna just let preach give you a
bunch
stupid that's one the [ __ ] on my lawn
you ungrateful [ __ ] that's two three
and four who raised you
that's father and six
get the [ __ ] out of here
greedy ass [ __ ] i don't know
where we at now
a bucks
man for real even the guy behind the
thing couldn't believe it he's like i
gave you eight bucks what more do you
want from me lady i don't think you
understand [ __ ] is you talking about
new york
that's what's over in new york
yo that ask me
[ __ ] give me talking about get my food
stupid [ __ ] you talking about ever
disrespect me looking like a ugly ass
hey man listen you know what right now
there's like a labor shortage a lot of
people are not happy with like their
shitty end jobs but sorry ladies
somebody giving you an eight dollar tip
is not an indication of that that you're
being spoiled right there you got
there's a bunch of delivery drivers
wishing they got half of that amount so
just stop playing around some of you
guys need to like humble yourselves or
maybe you're just not used to working i
don't know but whatever it is the fact
that you took back the food on top of
that
well i hope you can drop i hope sophie
urista finds you and pees on you i hope
you get stuck in a travis scott concert
all right maybe not that wow but you
know wow that's [ __ ] up is it that's
[ __ ] up yeah but if i was the person
who ordered food and you ran off with my
food i probably feel that way in that
moment
i'd be mad you ever had ordered food and
the [ __ ] ran off with it and
you've been sitting there for two hours
when you hungry [ __ ] die
that's so [ __ ] up
yeah
that's still [ __ ] up yeah yeah but you
know what
when you step home
like you've been on the road you've been
on the road you've been on the road you
get a little bit of road rage because
some dumb [ __ ] cuts you off no some
stupid ass [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah you
be wishing death on people all of a
sudden me never
hear no evil see no evil
i'm gonna erase my memory for a moment
so i don't incriminate nobody he never
yeah yeah never but anyways jokes aside
man listen stupid oh wow you're wow you
know one thing that's really stupid
about new york is that the state and the
capital city are the same name new york
new york yeah that's what really pisses
me off well it's the same thing here
what the capital of quebec is quebec
yeah it's also stupid
stupid at least it says quebec city only
in english and we're in we're in quebec
[Music]
it's english all day no as far as i'm
concerned yo yeah that's one thing i
always hate about new york new york new
york no no yeah you don't like that i
hate that so bruh i couldn't name this
something else
no it's a good name new york new york
it's a good name
let us know what you guys think in the
comments new york new york because of
the song
new york new york they talk about the
city